Tonight, former President
Donald Trump is heading to Rapid City,
South Dakota.
This marks his first public
rally since he was indicted
in Fulton County,
Georgia, on charges
related to overturning the last election.
Lest we forget, the last time
Trump was in South Dakota,
Governor Kristi
Noem offered him
a very nice miniature
replica of Mount Rushmore with Mr.
Trump's face on it.
This time, the governor may offer him
a presidential endorsement.
CNN's Kyung Lah is in Rapid City,
South Dakota.
Governor Noem,
very popular, but Trump arguably doesn't
need her endorsement. Right.
The fundamental right.
He doesn't necessarily
what this may be all about this evening
with CNN reporting
that Governor
Noem is expected to endorse him
this evening here.
Rapid City, South Dakota, state
that Republicans won by a very large
margin is more of a job interview.
He hasn't picked a vice president
yet, Jake.
And that really is what we're expecting
to see tonight,
an undercurrent
of a job application of sorts, Jake.
And Trump is known
for spending his time at rallies, sharing
sharing his various grievances.
Are we expecting him to introduce
any new policies this evening to
to help the American people as we see
Well, in short, no.
And there might be a reason
why he doesn't feel
he necessarily has to.
We spend some time talking to people
who were coming into this theater
to ask them what they want to hear.
What policies do you want?
One woman did say
she wants him to address inflation,
but she doesn't expect
any policy to come out of it
this evening.
What they want to hear from
him is the fight.
There are people
who are wearing his mug shot
from Fulton County.
I want you to listen to what they told us
when the president
This is
a picture of Trump
at his finest, being defiant
against the establishment
that is trying to take him down
in a political season.
Depends whose lie you're talking about.
You've got the court system
that is changing quite a bit
because they're what they state
is.
No, nothing.
Let's just say
it's a fight between good and evil.
And a lot of what's been happening
is evil.
He's bringing out the good.
I think he he looks out for his people.
I think he cares about us.
So what we'll be listening
for, Jake, is whether or not
the former
president addresses
any recent news,
especially today's news
out of Fulton County.
But as far as policy.
Not so much.
All right.
Kyung Lah in Rapid City, South Dakota,
thanks so much.